i can't really see though but actually
you have a pretty rad is that vinyl
buy new is that a collection of vinyl i
i do i have um
it goes all the way over there actually
most of it's over there but i do i have
a
uh i don't know if it's extensive it's
like 600 records i what that's amazing
i yeah i got into it just a couple of
years ago but um
there's this whole thing that goes along
with it and if you're a storyteller at
all or if you like stories
um you know you you have to pull the
record out you you take out
the vinyl you put it on the you know
there's the crackle
right of the needle and you're kind of
committing
i think at least to one side of an album
it just and it sounds different i think
it's the purest form
oh it sounds so it sounds like a nice
glass of wine that's what it sounds i
love vinyl i have a collection as well
but i i'm with you as far as
storytelling it's interesting even at
the beginning of my career
we would i mean sequencing was so
important and how where the songs went
on the album
and now people just don't even care you
know now it's almost coming back to
singles like to where you just put
singles in yeah but and you do miss a
story
yeah yeah of course i agree i love vinyl
um will you tell me about some of your
favorites now that i'm sitting here
looking at them
yeah i got um i pulled a few actually to
show you i
this one right here this was so this is
not the actual
album but it's it's a version of the
album that i got my very first album
when i was a really little kid actually
um
my parents got me this fisher price
really piece of garbage
nothing against fisher price but they
don't make you know high high
high grade audio equipment um and anyway
that that record player is long gone and
then um
this album is incredible it's this one
jam album that i think is a little bit
underrated
and there's a song on here called come
back which if you
if you're um if you're that's a really
sad song it's so sad but it's but it's
it's a wonderful um terrific song and
then you know i was thinking like
different
moods and one of the things everyone
always talks about this is us is like we
make people cry and stuff like that
and so i do have i do have that this
will make you cry
this is the complete the first season
this is this is an unbelievable album
it'll make you cry
but yeah you know i have a pretty
eclectic taste and
um the music ranges from jazz to blues
to rock to rap to whatever
i love it i'm i'm i'm a fan as well my i
think my first you had lionel richie
with the hair was amazing on that cover
my i think my first vinyl i think it was
patsy cline
i think it was my first yeah my my
mother that nothing was ever passed down
in our family the only thing i got
was her mother's vinyl collection and
they were like 45s
and a bunch of them and so um but they
were all like really cool and old school
but other than those like my first one i
bought i think was patsy klein you
should get some it's really nice to
listen to it just saying
um oh great okay is it it's a it's a
good album
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure